[Musique]
j'ai peur du monde qui vivent tragique
c'est un monde encore plus de solitude
pour un oui oui je crois
visage passe j'envisage pas l'avenir
c'est pas pensable
cette prolifération de l'être humain qui
est pire que celle du rage ce
d'effroyables les bêtes ne change pas
les bêtes sont merveilleuses passées
sont en contact direct avec la nature
est ce que répète est rue sauvé
l'humanité je crois c'est peut-être la
femme parce qu'elle est encore en
contact avec la nature
elle échappe aux lois aux imbécillité
demis pas même les anormaux
elle est encore en contact avec la
nature mais elle n'a pas voix au
chapitre
les animaux et l'homme les animaux vont
disparaître il ne restera plus bientôt
en afrique c'est dur c'est de
l'hécatombe permanent ici quand je suis
venu ici j'avais une trentaine de nids
d'hirondelles l'année passée j'ai deux
nids d'hirondelles et pour la première
fois j'ai ramassé une hirondelle qui
était tombé 200 nick était tellement si
pauvrement alimenté grâce aux progrès de
la science la science le chimique qui
assassine la terre qui assassine un sac
pias austin l'oiseau qui tue tout devis
qui assassine lamont s'en apercevoir
peut-être trop tard grâce à cela il n'ya
plus d'oiseaux je suis arrivé en 1933
c'était merveilleux le printemps c'est
une orgie de chants d'oiseaux c'était
quelque chose de merveilleux aujourd'hui
n'a plus je ramasse chaque chaque
printemps des oiseaux morts tombés du
nid où des oiseaux adultes mieux manger
des insectes empoisonné et qui meurt
[Musique]